know his apology is his apology but it
felt like it got
nothing more than a surface response on
any of this
michael strahan seems less than
impressed with chris harrison's apology
i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that on thursday the good
morning america anchor virtually spoke
with the bachelor host
for his first interview since coming
under fire last month
after an interview with former
bachelorette rachel lindsay
while speaking with lindsay harrison
defended current bachelor contestant
rachel kirkenl
who's been accused of past racist
behavior
after harrison's interview with strahan
aired the gma personality
had this to say his apology is his
apology but it felt like it got
nothing more than a surface response on
any of this and obviously
he's the man who wants to clearly stay
on the show
but only time will tell if there is any
meaning behind his words
during the interview with strahan
harrison opened up about the controversy
apologizing to the black community and
lindsay for his actions
and promising his commitment to learning
from his mistakes
i believe that mistake doesn't reflect
who i am
or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise i made a mistake
and i own that racism
oppression these are big dynamic
problems and they take serious work and
i am committed
to that work that mistake was what
happened during this
february conversation with lindsay when
harrison defended kirknell
after the 24 year old bachelor
contestant was accused of liking racist
photos on social media
bullying a woman for dating black men
and attending an old south plantation
party when she was in college in 2018.
the picture was reported from 2018
at an old south antebellum parties so i
think
you know when you when you it's
when you hold that it's not a good one
it's not a good one no
it's not a good well rachel is it a good
look in 2018 or is it not a good look in
2021
because there's a now harrison says
he sees he was wrong antebellum parties
are not okay past present
future knowing what that represents
is unacceptable harrison is currently
taking time away from the show
and will not host bachelor matt james's
after the final rose special
stepping in former nfl star and author
of uncomfortable conversations with a
black man
emmanuel ocho who will host the show
airing march
15th as for whether harrison plans to
return to the dating franchise series
i plan to be back and i want to be back
this interview
is not the finish line there is much
more work to be done
and i am excited to be a part of that
[Music]
change